knowing that you just captured
a person who wanted to kill kavanaugh
and his family
so was he not
in any threat
yesterday
is he not in any threat
after schumer
made his threats on the supreme court
jan sackey said it was the president's
position to go to those homes
i have no idea why the democrats have
held that bill for one month i have no
idea
i think they might be playing politics
and speaking of that
speakers pelosi's select committee on
january 6 is unlike any other committee
in american history
in fact it is the most political
and least legitimate committee in
american history
it has used congressional subpoenas to
attack republicans
violate due process
and infringe on the political speech of
private citizens
it has actually been caught
altering evidence
including the text messages of our
ranking member jim jordan
it has permanently damaged the house and
divided this country
and let's be honest it is a smoke screen
for democrats to push the radical agenda
you read it in just an axios just this
week
the battles internally because what do
they want to do they want to federalize
the elections
and they're talking about their real
outcome of want what they want to
achieve abolish the electoral college
all the while that the democrats are
ignoring
really
what is affecting the american people
the highest inflation in more than 40
years
record high gas prices
doubled since president biden has taken
office
lack of baby formula unsecured border
fentanyl coming across
now the number one killer of americans
between the ages of 18 and 45.
now let's be very clear
the violence at the capitol that day was
wrong
and we have repeatedly denounced it
but keeping the capital safe
is not the point
of pelosi's illegitimate select
committee
from the beginning the select committee
refused to investigate the real
circumstances that led to the right
including the lack of security around
the capital
they also ignored
the left-wing mob violence which led to
riots
and loss of life across the country that
summer
when house republicans proposed
investigating these facts
as you'll remember on january 12th
we put it to the floor and every single
democrat voted no
when i sent pelosi a letter after they
voted no she did not respond for three
months
and she jumped to create a select
committee
not only that
she rejected
the minorities picks to be on the
committee
that's going against
232 years of a tradition in this house
you reject the minority to have a say
in the committee
who did she reject
congressman jim banks
to distinguish afghanistan veteran
she rejected congressman jim jordan he's
the ranking and maybe soon to be chair
of judiciary committee
now why she rejected these qualified
republicans
she appointed radical democrats
you ever spend any time to see who's on
it
she appointed chairman thompson
who to be clear
objected to the presidential electors in
2005.
she appointed congressman raskin
who also objected to the presidential
electors in 2017
but let's not forget
what else he said
he called for president trump's
impeachment
not during his term in office
but between him when he was elected and
being sworn in
and then she appointed congressman shift
just saying that name should be enough
but we watched what shift has done to
our country
the years of lying about the russian
hoax
the changing of evidence we found as he
went and the denying of the hunter biden
laptop
you know our future rests on the ability
of americans to trust our political
system
to have safer streets
to have affordable food
and gas
and to have confidence that their
elected officials are listening to real
concerns
now democrats are using january 6 to
avoid accountability
for making the late the whole nation
less safe
and less prosperous
you know it you feel it you see it every
single day
every single day the food prices go up
and along with the gas
not sure if we caught another
individual coming across the border
illegal that's on
the terrorist watch list
not sure if there's anybody else that
wants to come across the board illegal
to try to assassinate former president
bush
not sure if the plane
from australia bringing goat milk to try
to feed the children of america
that's the america we have today
i don't see any prime time
hearing set for gas price
for battling inflation
for feeding our children
for making the streets safer you know
even in the hometown of the speaker this
tuesday
they recalled
their d.a based upon the democratic
policies
of not upholding safe streets
and don't think it was republicans
rallied together because you know how
many republicans are registered in san
francisco 6.7 percent
but lo and behold
i'm not sure if they're using taxpayer
money to hire a former a b c executive
who took his time
to withhold information about epstein
or if they're doing it for their ice
cream
but i do know
the american public will not be fooled
and i do know the republicans will not
be deterred that we will continue to
focus on the parts that america wants us
to
to make america energy independent
to make our streets safe in our schools
again
to secure our border
to know that america
and the next century will be ours
with that
even though
speaker pelosi
has rejected republicans ability to
participate
we said we'd get to the bottom of this
we said we would not
brush it under the rug and we have not
we continue to investigate
leading that
which would be our ranking member on
this committee
is chairman jim banks
who is a
veteran to afghanistan
serves as the chair of our largest
conference
inside the republican conference and has
continued to work on to make sure that
this building will be safe and in the
future this will never happen again i
give you jim banks
i thank the leader
and as he said the american people know
that this select committee is already a
fraud democrats aren't investigating
january 6. that's already very
abundantly clear
as the leader said they're trying to use
this select committee as a trojan horse
to abolish the electoral college
to intimidate president trump's aides
to block him from ever appearing on the
ballot again
and to prevent his supporters from
participating in american democracy
gas today in my hometown in columbia
city indiana is 5.25 cents a gallon
but in washington the democrats top
priority
is an hour-long made-for-tv special
attacking president trump
americans aren't buying it
voters see that even after nearly two
years of joe biden the democrats still
refuse to lead
they refuse to take responsibility for
the serious economic difficulties that
they have created
and the democrats refuse to help the
american people and families who are
hurting because of their policies
but the select committee is ignoring its
most basic
duty the democrats aren't asking the
simple questions about what happened on
january six
before their investigation even started
speaker pelosi
turned the select committee into an
unprecedented sham
she blocked jim jordan and i for sure to
serve on the select committee it's never
happened before in american history
and no speaker in history has ever done
something as partisan as that
as what speaker pelosi has done but why
does she do it
she did it because she's afraid
speaker pelosi doesn't really want a
real investigation into january 6th
that's why her sergeant-at-arms refused
to cooperate with a bipartisan senate
committee investigation
she was afraid of what they would in
uncover
the house republicans continued to
conduct our own ad hoc
investigation into january 6.
our goal is to answer the questions
that this select committee is ignoring
questions that you're not going to hear
about on the prime time special tonight
questions that must be answered to keep
congress
and the capitol police officers safe in
the future
and here are the questions that you
should be demanding answers from from
the select committee members as well
first of all
how is it possible that the capitol
police we now know
was half staffed
because of covid
on january 6th
second
why were our officers under equipped on
that day
why were some officers forced to face
down a riot without helmets or expired
equipment
why were the capitol police officers
never trained to handle a riot even
after all of the riots that were ongoing
in washington dc in our nation's capital
in the summer of 2020.
did speaker pelosi communicate with the
house sergeant-at-arms on january 6 or
in the days leading up to the riot
why didn't the capitol police's
intelligence unit raise the alarm about
potential violence when they had
intelligence going back weeks before
january 6 that told them that something
was going to happen
why did the fbi deploy commandos to
quantico
on january 3rd
with shoot to kill authority but failed
to send the united states capitol police
a single threat assessment or
intelligence intelligence bulletin
was speaker pelosi involved in the
decision to delay national guard
assistance
on january sixth
those are serious
and real questions that this committee
committee refuses
to even ask
speaker pelosi doesn't want to answer
those questions because she knows that
the answers to those questions leave a
trail of breadcrumbs right back to her
office
underscoring her negligence her lack of
leadership as the speaker of the house
those are serious questions that we will
continue to dig into
our report will be coming and the we
will be finished in the weeks to come
and we will present to you serious
issues
and recommendations of what congress and
the next speaker of the house can do to
provide better leadership and secure the
united states capital so that something
like january 6 never happens again with
that thank you i yield to whip scalise
thank you jim and jim banks just raised
some very serious questions
that should be answered
by the january 6 commission but they're
not
and they're not for a very specific
reason and that's because nancy pelosi
doesn't want those questions to be
answered
in fact she took the unprecedented step
of kicking jim banks and jim jordan off
of the january 6 committee because they
were going to ask those questions that a
lot of people would like the answers to
so when you hear them talking about it's
all about getting to the truth if they
really believed in getting to the truth
they would have kept
jim banks and jim jordan on the
committee to ask those questions and get
the truth
that's not what this has been about
never was
to nancy pelosi it was always about
politics and if there was any doubt that
it was about politics nancy pelosi
removed that doubt when she took the
unprecedented step of kicking
the republicans
off of the committee that leader
mccarthy
had appointed
and so it begs the question as we go
around the country as i go around my
district
we're all being asked the same questions
the questions our constituents are
asking
is what is congress going to do
to help alleviate the problems that are
hurting families in south louisiana
all across the country what are they
going to do to lower inflation to lower
gas prices to secure america's border
that's the questions families are asking
me
and my colleagues around the country
i was just on the floor a few minutes
ago and asked
leader hoyer if he would bring up a bill
that we have house republicans have put
together
a broad package of legislation to lower
gas prices
and they refuse nancy pelosi and all of
her minions refuse to bring bills like
that to the floor
so as you're watching tonight
however many watch
i think it's important to note
what
prime time lineup is not included by
nancy pelosi
is nancy pelosi going to hold a prime
time hearing on inflation
i'd sure like to see that i think a lot
of americans would
is nancy pelosi going to hold a prime
time hearing on lowering gas prices
they've refused to so far they won't
even bring a bill to the floor that will
lower gas prices and everybody knows
what needs to happen to lower gas prices
because just two years ago we were
paying about two dollars a gallon at the
pump and today we're paying way more
than double that in many places well
over five dollars a gallon
when we know the answer and it's not joe
biden going to saudi arabia and begging
opec begging monopolies begging
dictators begging putin to produce more
oil
when the oil we need to secure america's
energy
security as well as our economic
security is right here beneath our feet
we've got the energy here and by the way
we produce it cleaner than anywhere else
in the world
and so whatever his carbon footprint is
going to be to go to fly to saudi arabia
to talk about saving the planet by
asking them to produce energy because
he's beholden to the radical left who
don't want to produce energy in america
why don't we have a hearing on that why
don't we have a hearing on the border
crisis we could maybe invite vice
president kamala harris who joe biden
put in charge of it she's yet to go to
the border
this crisis is not just at our southern
border it's touching every community in
america
the fentanyl that's killing thousands of
young kids every single year
that fentanyl is coming across our
southern border because joe biden has
turned operational control of america's
border over to drug cartels
where's that hearing
baby formula there was just a report
yesterday
that came out that said joe biden's fda
knew last year that there was going to
be a crisis
with baby formula
he didn't even have an fda commissioner
until just a few months ago he went a
whole year without an fda commissioner
and you wonder why the fda was a
ruthless ship under joe biden why don't
we have a hearing on that during prime
time of course we know that this has
always been about politics tonight
you're going to see it's about politics
and most importantly the questions that
jim banks her raised are not going to be
asked tonight and should be and with
that i want to bring up our conference
chair elise stefan
thank you to the whip
nancy pelosi's sham committee is
illegitimate and its sole purpose is to
punish democrats political opponents it
will not prevent another january 6 from
happening it is not about finding out
why nancy pelosi left the capitol so ill
prepared on that day and it does
absolutely nothing to address the
numerous crises americans are suffering
from every single day because of joe
biden nancy pelosi's radical far-left
agenda
the truth is house democrats have no
agenda for americans and no real
solutions to the problems that we face
on a daily basis and they are
desperately shamelessly trying to change
the narrative but the american people
are smart they see this for exactly what
it is a desperate partisan distraction a
circus to focus on to move the focus
away from the issues that actually
impact people's lives
house republicans we will continue to
focus on the issues that matter to the
american people and to how to solve the
numerous crises joe biden and house
democrats agenda has created
historically high gas prices that have
now doubled since joe biden took office
over seventy percent of our nation's
baby formula is out of stock in my home
district i have a nine month old they
are rationing baby formula this is the
united states of america folks this is
unacceptable and it's directly because
of joe biden inflation is at a 40-year
high higher than any point in my
lifetime
violent crime continues to skyrocket
because of democrats soft on crime
policies and one of the one of possibly
the largest migrant caravans ever is
headed to our southern border house
republicans have an agenda and are
focused on these issues house democrats
are focusing on this partisan witch hunt
and i'm proud to turn it over to our
leader leader mccarthy
let's open up for some questions
yes sir
uh mr banks post these questions
speaker pelosi
will you be asking the same questions to
mitch mcconnell he also had an appointee
on the capitol police department senate
sergeant-at-arms will you ask them those
same questions you want about capital
security
yes because we want to get to the bottom
of why this capital was so
ill-prepared
um
there's reports that um
was offered national guard as early as
january second
we do not know why they weren't here
i've seen intel reporting
after this it watched that the crowd got
out of control people were warned ahead
of time they were offering of a national
guard we'd like to know to the bottom of
why they weren't there
jonathan how are you oh thank you um can
you just clarify something do you
believe that joe biden was the
legitimate victor of the 2020 election
and do you believe that donald trump is
just flat wrong when he says the
election was stolen look uh we've
answered this question a long time
joe biden is the president i think you
can look that there's a lot of problems
still within the election process they
just arrested a former democratic
congressman just the other was it
yesterday in pennsylvania and
philadelphia um and as we find a lot
more information out there we want to
make sure more people have the ability
to vote and that it's secure and with
the election where we're going for this
question that wasn't the question yeah
your question your question was in the
white house was it legitimate is donald
trump wrong when he says the election
was stolen you know jonathan we've
talked about this a long time i've
already answered that question thank you
thank you we'll move on now thank you
very much thank you very much
thank you so you won't answer that
jonathan i've answered it numerous times
i know you have a microphone i know what
you want to do i've already answered the
questions
thank you is he wrong
thank you for your time go right ahead
could i get a show of hands on the stage
who plans to watch the hearing tonight
of when your alternative report will
actually come out
uh and
any other member
and how many people are actually
cooperating with the uh with mr banks's
alternative investigation so if you're
asking if we've already have on amazon
for people to purchase the report and
the date no i know but that's what the
democrats have so i mean if you're
wondering if it's if ours is going to be
political like that no but our report
will come out uh soon and we'll let you
know when it
with this is but even still we have seen
numerous members from the trump white
house even some members of the
president's own family former president
that is appear before this committee so
why not testify why not be transparent
well let's let's raise that question all
right am i transparent so the committee
asked if i would come talk to them so i
sent them a letter to ask what they want
to talk about they never responded
what they said publicly went out there
they said they wanted to talk about my
conversation with the president on
january 6. so on january 6 when i had
that conversation with the president i
then went on three networks one with i
think i was even with you jonathan i had
a longer discussion with the american
public than my conversation with the
president so there was nothing to be
added
to go about and then the argument of
whether you could subpoena members
themselves it purely looks to me like
it's political we sent a letter back
raised a lot of questions about this
because the first hand that you would
have to realize is if you go to quinn
watkins the supreme court
has told
the congress about the separations of
power
does the committee have a legitimate
legislative purpose yes but we have a
separation of power the legitimate
legislative purpose would be exactly
what the senate bipartisan committee did
they believe they want to be like an
attorney general or something that's why
it's done the committee was passed the
rule by congress to say it would have 13
members it does not have 13 members the
committee said that they could either
have you come in or write you questions
we said we'd answer they would not do
that the committee says in the setup
that they would confer with the ranking
member there is no ranking member
because i have not appointed anyone
so there are so many bases of why this
political committee does not have a true
standing at the basis of where they're
going think about this for one moment
they hire some from buddy from abc
who withheld information about epstein
they knew it and they still hired it are
they using taxpayer money for that they
set up watching parties where they give
free ice cream who's paying for that the
d triple c
they pick prime time when the when
gasoline has doubled since the president
has been in inflation we have not seen
in 41 years
you're flying in goat milk from
australia to try to feed the american
babies will they bring any of that up no
it's a it's a political driven committee
they already have the date set on amazon
to buy it now why did they prolong it
why do they pick daylight why are they
picking before the election it's the
only thing they have when the american
people are hungry to solve so many other
problems yes
yes there was some heartbreaking
testimony yesterday and the day before
from families who have suffered
devastating losses in the past couple of
weeks ago
and you and many members here advocated
for more school
looking at mental health that seems to
be something that
everyone is talking about in the senate
in addition to that though there is
conversation about
what to do to figure out who in this
kind of profile that you see of young
men especially
how you can figure out
who might act violently how you can flag
that
can you talk to me about your thinking
on whether incentives for red flag laws
could be helpful in that and what that
could look like including your process
concerns i know you have those but is
there any kind of red flag incentive
that you think would be helpful and i
ask this because families are looking
for something more they agree with what
you're saying on schools and doesn't
help but they want
more than that and what are you willing
for i don't think i just don't think
family i have a family too i think
everybody in america wants this
i think the devastation we're seeing is
horrendous
i i actually wish the house would do
exactly what the senate to sit down and
have a discussion
we were back in session on tuesday at 6
30 and we voted on bills on wednesday
it's the same thing like the committee
it was a political show
why would you bring up a red flag bill
and not bring anything about due process
look don't think it's from republic i
was watching tulsi gabbert a minute ago
on television talking about this as well
who was a democrat nominee for president
if we are able to find and prevent
everybody's life there wasn't one mental
health advice here there wasn't one
discussion ahead of time there was no
time to work together i was just talking
to
senator cornyn
this is the way to handle it find all
the facts
you know i want to highlight congressman
tony gonzalez this is his district
his district has gone through so much
he's been on the ground there listening
to families listening what's going on
but it's just like everywhere else we've
watched this tragic situation happen
before you know what we found a shooting
in texas another one this individual
came in and shot up a church
the church is back just now like a
museum you know what we found this
individual
was in the military dishonorably
discharged abused his wife never should
have been able to have a weapon
and when we were in the majority finding
those facts we passed the fixed things
to make sure that would be on the right
there is a way to go about doing this
and that's sitting down making sure
you're dealing with all the issues at
once instead of playing the political
game and unfortunately that's what nancy
pelosi chose and i know from that same
point this is the same speaker that told
us the supreme court is safe this
weekend but they weren't safe yesterday
and she has a bill on the floor right
now that a hundred percent senators
voted for that she wouldn't bring yes
with the exception of congressman davis
all of you on that stage voted against
of independent commission 911 style that
was crafted by your own ranking member
john catko to investigate the facts and
circumstances of january 6th okay well
let me explain that that commission
would have been devoid of current
politicians and would have required a
bipartisan buy-in to issue satinas okay
on january 12 can you explain
why
all all of you
dave has voted against that and
what uh in you all are now doing your
own investigation into into the sixth
um what uh what in your in your opinion
uh brought all of those rioters to the
capitol on that day
okay so let me answer your question you
say we voted against a commission
on january 12 we offered the commission
and put it on the floor and every single
democrat voted against it was on 9 11.
pelosi wouldn't bring it up so we sent
her a letter three months later before
she responded
i'm not sure if you'd been into these
press conferences before that i do
weekly but we would talk about that week
after week when nancy pelosi wanted to
negotiate about she wanted to eliminate
what we could look at she wanted the
scope to be very narrow in that time why
she waited we lost another officer on
the gate over here by a terrorist attack
to run over and had to go and had a
knife she said we couldn't look at that
we couldn't look at what had happened in
america just that short time before the
riots in the streets that have been
going over
riots threw out riots that were in this
city as well and what she did i'll
answer your question thank you and what
we did within that process we wanted to
have a 911 we want to have a scope we
offered it we put it on the floor we
voted for it pelosi played nothing but
politics delayed it and then when they
moved to this equation we offered people
to be on this committee
that's the rules the select committee to
the minority to put people on for 232
years that's been the history of this
house but nancy pelosi said no
why well she didn't participate with the
senate bipartisan committee maybe she
didn't want people to be able to
question it's american history
look across the street at the supreme
court
we've got that statue
for the blindfold of the scale to be
fair
she wanted to make sure it was
not and she wanted to pick and choose
who could be on that we didn't have the
right never before in the history it
allowed them to be
to know we didn't participate with the
political scam we offered it six days
after january 6 a 9 11 committee write
it the way it happened yes uh lena
mccarthy you said both publicly and
privately after january 6 that you
thought trump for some responsibility
for the attack do you still feel like he
was in any way responsible for judges
i've answered that many times i thought
everybody in the country beared some
responsibility based upon what has been
going on the riots on the streets the
others
having spent time and seeing what's
going forward
what happened
in january 2nd
when the national guard was offered to
protect this guy
prior to
january 6
we had a problem at this game where they
broke through the police
and the kavanagh here
what change took there
there's a legislative purpose
for congress to look at you have a
separation of powers
pelosi continues to play politics
just the same reason why
she won't do anything to let america
become energy independent
she won't do anything to make sure those
supreme court justices are going to be
safe over the weekend by unanimous
consent that's all it took one member on
the floor to sing
yes leader mccarthy should voters punish
members who voted in favor of the
january 6 commission
well i don't know because thompson
oh voted in favor of the january 6th
commission the creation
yeah and also about chris jacobs chris
jacobs couldn't run after what he said
about assault weapons
so what is your uh well
he could have ran he was exactly but
what is your opinion about that decision
not to run after you got such backlash
from members of the party and member
voters
i don't remember saying one thing about
chris jacobs right
jacobs
leader mccarthy duke with newsmax many
in the media and democrats characterize
what happened on january 6 as an
insurrection and it's become really the
de facto term to describe the events of
that day was january 6 that insurrection
and if not what what words what term
would you use to describe
what that object january 6 happened on
the capital is wrong
those who broke in the capital were
wrong and should be dealt with and
that's exactly what we have in the
process
police the fbi to deal with the role
within congress
we should look at why we're so
ill-prepared that day and how do we
protect it yes sir leader mccarthy why
do you think people storm the capital
and do you think that motivation
deserves to be investigated
yeah that's what the fbi did thank you
so two-part question here
a number of your members i don't know if
you've said this specifically a number
of your members have said if you take
the majority you'll launch
investigations into hunter biden i'm
curious what the legislative
angle is on that and number two what
will you do if people look at your
investigations if you're in the majority
and say they're illegitimate we're not
gonna we're not gonna respond to this
because we won't be illegitimate we
won't say democrats won't be on
committee we will we won't uh issue
subpoenas for political
going after our political opponents
we'll do exactly what congress is
supposed to do we'll uphold the
constitution if there's a place for us
to investigate we'll investigate
yes sir thank you um if republicans take
over the house next year would you
commit to holding a vote on that
independent uh commission legislation
that you initially proposed in january
of 2021 to have this
out of politics
right now we'll see what that turns out
paul kane how are you today fantastic
are you in a good mood sure i worry
about you
so
so you have cited your phone calls to
then president trump to questions that
john
he told the authors jonathan martin and
alex burns that there was no angry call
at all and that your description of the
call that was on air and that you told
other members was wrong and they asked
why would he
mischaracterize the phone call and he
told them on the record in an interview
inferiority complex
who is right
i don't know
i don't know i don't think you do i
don't know
who's good version of the call was right
i think you you can judge whatever
there's two people on the call and two
people know what happened on the call i
spoke to the american public
leader mccarthy you've laid out why you
haven't participated in the
investigation when they've asked me you
know i've been denied the right to
participate so um your lawyer had sent a
letter with questions have they gotten
back to you and if so if if so
will you commit to participate either by
written testimony or in person i never
said i wouldn't participate you know the
very first came up
um
i said you put the republican members on
then it's a legitimate commitment they
had they answered me but they didn't
answer all my questions
so i sent them another letter and they
haven't answered do you plan to make
that letter public
i can't there's no problem
last question
what are the chances
to put a number on it what are the
chances of you
speaking to the community at this point
and also
would republicans in the majority
consider submitting democratic members
of congress
you know it's interesting i had a
discussion with the majority leader
today and you talked about if i was to
become speaker he was concerned about
the stuff within the house i would just
remind the democrats
they're the ones who've changed all the
rules they are the ones who broke all
traditions
they removed a member of congress
something they said that person said
before they were ever a member of
congress
they pick and choose who could be on
committees they denied a 232-year
history
of whether the minority could even offer
people on a committee
they
they find members based upon what they
believed right and wrong
they allowed people to vote with never
even being here they take away the
minorities right to even have an
amendment on the floor
i think it's the democrats who changed
how the house works
if we happen to keep that same pattern
it would be the democrats who changed
the rules and we just followed them are
you interesting if they would like that
or not are you going to keep that
pattern
you know these are all hypotheticals i
think we should definitely see what the
outcome has i do believe the american
public is looking for people
who will focus on the issues they care
most about
we'll make a congress that actually
works for them
not a congress for their own personal
belief to change an election
not a congress that will raise your
price of gasoline and cause inflation
not a prop not a congress that makes a
border insecure
i think what they're really looking for
is a new direction and i believe
in 153 more days that will happen
and it will be a new congress that works
for the american public it will follow
the constitution it'll be one that makes
us energy independent
inflation down
secure our border make our streets and
schools safe again
and yes we will be stronger and more
prosperous thank you for attending
okay
um
you